baptisé Louis Pasteur la nouvelle maison
médicale de Ben se trouve en face du
supermarché G20 route de Frileuse un
projet lancé en 2018 durant l'ancienne
mandature qui devenait de plus en plus
urgent pour cette commune rurale de 7000
habitants il y a quelques années on a
perdu des médecins qui ont déménagé sont
partis dans une autre maison médicale et
donc il était urgent de faire en sorte
que les médecins trouvent un lieu et qui
s'approprie ce lieu pour travailler dans
l'excellente conditions voilà et donc
c'était le but c'est de ne pas perdre
les médecins et puis d'en trouver
d'autres et cette nouvelle maison de
santé pluridisciplinaire attire elle
comprend déjà trois médecins
généralistes un dentiste deux
infirmières de podologues une
diététicienne et bientôt deux
orthophonistes c'est plus confortable je
pense que pour les patients c'est plus
confortable aussi du fait de
l'accessibilité de l'offre de soins ça
peut permettre de en même temps aller
voir d'autres confrères
c'est un plus pour pour tout le monde je
pense c'est plus agréable et je
cherchais toute façon comme un peu tous
les médecins de nouveaux médecins en
général on cherche à s'installer avec
d'autres pour avoir des collègues à côté
c'est toujours de travailler en groupe
c'est toujours plus agréable donc c'est
en général ce qu'on cherche les maisons
de santé c'est pas mal pour ça cette
nouvelle maison de santé est également
une aubaine pour les habitants aux
alentours de Beynes puisque elle est un
petit peu plus proche de chez moi une
consultation parce que mon médecin va te
mettre un traitant il était à
Neauphle-le-Château et a pris sa
retraite et donc j'ai le médecin m'a
repris ma bien accepté de me prendre
comme nouveau patient je suis suivi en
fait par le docteur qui était déjà à Ben
avant et qui vient après de s'installer
ici on est suivi mon conjoint moi et la
petite donc c'est parfait aujourd'hui
complète à 75% la maison médicale Louis
Pasteur cherche encore un médecin
généraliste des médecins spécialistes et
des kinésithérapeutes pour compléter son
offre de soins coût total de l'opération
3,1 million d'euros subventionné par le
département à hauteur de 1,1 million
d'euros et par l'ARS à hauteur de 250
000 euros